the internet and digital technologies
are transforming our world
every work life every line of business
but europe needs to change to become
competitive again
fragmentation and barriers within our
single market are holding digital back
you can drive from italian to touring
without once showing your passport but
you can't stream
your favorite tv shows from home once
you get there
you still pay more to order a website
from a country just next door
and faced with different laws
very few small businesses can sell
across borders in eu
one year ago i promised to make creating
a fully digital single market one of my
top priorities as commission president
and we are making good on that promise
we are making the single market fit for
a digital edge
even techies like me
know
that technology has to be our future
you